Not every trait fits neatly into one category
or another. For example, height is something that
we can pretty easily identify as being physical,
but something like intelligence is something that's a
little more harder to categorize. Intelligence might be
something that you describe as behavioral and not
physical, unless you define it by the number
or pattern of neuroconnections in the brain In
which case that might seem more physical. It could also
be visible or hidden, depending on whether you look at
the product of intelligence or the abstract nature of it.
It is also still debated how much intelligence may be learned,
or how much of it may be innate. Can you
think of another trait that is hard to define in these
categories? Try to use a one word answer and remember,
there's no right or wrong response here. Just want to get
you to think about which traits could be hard to catagorize.